As you can see, your pattern is scored based on the number 10, so out of 10 is your 1.
As you can see, it's split up into two parts.
We have our accuracy and our presentation on this side.
So we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy is actually scored from a 4.
So from the number 4, you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern.
And then with that one, any mistakes that you make, if it's a minor mistake, you get a minus of 0.1.
If it's a major mistake, you get minus 0.3.
So I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So with a minor mistake, it's very, very small.
Is it possible if we watch it in my video?
If it's not your shoulder height, you can forward if you feel like we know already.
That's a minor mistake.
If it's a 15 mistake in the 20 patterns, sorry, in the 20 steps.
So the reason for that one being, it needs to be absolutely perfect to get, to not say there's 20 steps and you made 15 steps.
So what would that be?
We'll leave that there.
On this side, we'll come back and we'll just calculate this one year.
So a score of 2 is your power and speed.
Your rhythm is also a score of 2.
So you do need to kind of work on your rhythm, and that's also a score of 2.
The last thing is your expression of energy.
So what is the expression of energy?
That's basically how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well.
So let's say you're doing your pattern really well, it's really fast and it's strong, your rhythm is really great, but you're not shouting very loud.
Or you can kind of tell, the judges can kind of tell, oh, you're not really confident, or you're a little bit nervous, so that's why we need to kind of improve on that as well.
So let's come around to this side.
So with this one, four color belts and black belts, it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So if you're a color belt, you'll actually, your average, so where the judges actually mark you from, it's actually from a 1.1.
So this is your average.
So say you did, you did alright, you did average against everyone else, your score will be 1, 2, and 3.
You might go down to, say for your power and speed, you might get a 1, or you get a 0.9.
If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So each individual category, you need to obviously get as high as you can.
If you're a black belt, generally depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3.
So 1.3 would be your average, let's just start from.
So say your power and speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average.
This is, with the judges, we have three judges usually at the panel, and each judge obviously is very subjective.
So from their point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes, or you may have made not a lot of mistakes at all.
So that's why we have the three judges.
It's not uncommon, generally for a color belt, the average is about a 4 to 5.
So if you get a number between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern, that's actually generally considered.
We just went through our full day scoring, so just remember, accuracy is a 4.0, presentation is a 6.0,
and might be a 5.something, another guy on the other side has scored a little bit higher.
So we get three numbers, and then we average that as well.
So I hope this helps you guys, so make sure you enjoy your full day competition,
and make sure, obviously, you record down your numbers.
So we're going to read your performance.
Okay, so minor errors, major errors, we cannot pause this time, but you can.
Yeah.
Is it possible that you'll, like, watch my video?
You're going to watch it right now, yeah.
And you cannot pause, like, a real judge.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.